battles for his family's future
zelica
raises a murderous young Army against
violent Rivals
the innocent will have to fight
for their share of the Kingdom
[Music]
and there will be no mercy
tensions in the mass Pride are beginning
to boil
the shimmering heat takes its toll
sekacama has a decision to make
his oldest son sir kedi should have been
expelled by now
that the King has allowed him to stay
now circadi lust for power and speaks
out of turn
challenging Rule and ruler
[Music]
deliberate contempt
give an inch and they'll take it all
all new on knees
[Music]
you are all my subjects
thank you
timana and malau have heard it all
before
dear clear of the king
but everything they need is on his Marsh
[Music]
second Karma May rule
but the pale pack needs their share
and they will fight for it
[Music]
they may be only five
but malau and his brother are
exceptional Hunters
malau leads this Heist
a tactical strike deep into anime
territory
stay low
eyes open
ears back
the Marsh pride does not take prisoners
and the pale pack can't afford to lose a
single member
timana barely has enough soldiers as it
is
no point running
[Music]
we can go on forever
attack formation
hit him from all sides
there's no time to kill
eat him
live
his suffering is over
yeah
they must hurry news travels fast in the
great Marsh
Rivals are watching
where there's one there will be more
the Marsh's last Waterhole is becoming a
sanctuary
salika Queen of the Shadow Army covets
this water
control it and she could rule the world
but she's not alone
they have a painful history
the pale pack killed zalika's daughter
all right
this will not happen again
malau and his brother are forced to
retreat
but zalika's Victory is short-lived
the Marsh pride is here
with me
we do not tolerate vermin
selika has no choice but to leave
[Music]
the Marsh pride has had outnumbered and
outgunned
[Music]
the cracks are starting to show
trouble is brewing
too
Celica is not the only one with a grudge
against the king
if the Marsh pride lowers its guard
she will be ready
a rebel Army grows in the shadows
future foot soldiers built to conquer
the great Marsh
born with teeth they fight from day one
[Music]
salika's turn is no Nursery
this is a training camp
[Music]
to take the marsh
they must face their greatest Fears Head
On
[Music]
one monster at a time
while her child soldiers train
selika gathers intelligence
to fuel their growing Army the sisters
roam in search of the dead and the dying
for the wounded
under the cloak of Darkness
they Feast on the Fallen
[Music]
foreign
but no secret stays hidden for long
the stench of death carries
malau and his brother have arrived
with the whole clan
A specter at the feast
malau's brother leads the attack
[Music]
foreign
she will be back
next time with reinforcements
[Applause]
[Music]
hurry get your Fame
and clear out
come on
back through enemy territory
back to the den
to the insatiable hunger of their
bloodthirsty Young
Renegades in training
[Music]
behold the future of the pale pack
allow and his brother know it's
dangerous to remain in one place
the family can't stay here much longer
salikas spy
do not let her Escape untouched
teach on a lesson
run for your life
and tell zelika to stay away
but somewhere in The Clash malaw's
brother is wounded
their bravest Hunter
is out of commission
without his brother malau knows that in
serious trouble
sakakama's Fortune shrinks by the day
as the marsh dries out the herds head
north in search of food
the Marsh pride must seize what's left
before it's gone
everyone must do their part
matsumi and her sisters are the real
talent
[Music]
foreign
before the king
the disrespect knows no bounds
oh
many times must you be told
wait your turn
the victim seizes on the chaos
foreign
hunting is hard enough
hunting the same victim twice
is wasted energy
allowed his sons to stay
and this is how they repay him
their lack of discipline nearly costs
The Pride everything
[Music]
the king is not amused
especially with the kitty
the ringleader
his oldest son will pay the penalty for
disrespect
no supper for you
[Music]
left to wallow in resentment
a hungry lion is an angry lion
second Karma's iron rule is all that's
keeping these Cubs alive
he knows how dangerous circetti is
but his world is crumbling fast
and like it or not
they are strongest together
[Music]
the marsh Prides wealth is Vanishing as
The Exodus continues
The Pride looks for leadership
weighs up what's left in his kingdom
[Music]
thank you
best stay out of his way
he's in no mood for competition
zalika builds her secret army in the
midst of hell
they're growing strong
vicious
but the older they get
the harder it is to keep them Secret
and second karma is on the war path
[Music]
selika returns from the night shift
to find her Dan as silent as the grave
foreign
[Music]
there is no time to mourn
zelika loses one of her own
it's the price of building an army
malau and timana don't have that luxury
thank you
they need every single member of the
pack
but my last brother wounded there are
not enough soldiers to survive
the pups are still young
but they must learn to kill
now
quiet down
this is not a game
[Music]
allow zeroes in on a victim
but his cover is blown
[Music]
foreign
stealth
this could be a youthful lesson
split up
Circle the target
but teeth and booze can maim and shatter
but the first sign of danger
pups Run for Cover
too young for Duty
foreign
[Music]
but games won't fill empty bellies
circadi and his brothers know where they
stand with their father
so they carry favor with their mothers
the real power behind the throne
why is matsumi plays politics well
balancing loyalty to her sons
and duty to her King
foreign
but if he were ever to rule
he would kill her Cubs
sakakama knows what this means
he's seen it all before
when he became king
that must not happen
thank you
some lines you cross only once
no more warnings
This Is War
[Music]
foreign
it's more than just a slap in the face
circuities blows and shock waves
if the king can be hurt
he can be overthrown
foreign
[Music]
nothing will ever be the same again
the pale pack faces its own turmoil
they've not eaten in days
they must kill soon
with malala's brother still out of
action
it's now up to the pups
finally they're beginning to show
promise
foreign
close
but close doesn't heat
now the whole Marsh is on alert
despite their failure malau sees a
glimmer of hope
they will be hunters and lead the pale
pack
just not today
salika has spies everywhere
watching her enemies mistakes
foreign
coup
sirketti lies low
he landed a lucky blow
but he took a beating
and he knows right now
sakakama could destroy him
circadia persuades his brothers
it's time we left
[Music]
no one tries to stop them
foreign
young princes
[Music]
his three treacherous Sons intend to
prove they have what it takes
what they lack and experience
they make up for with arrogance
[Music]
um
security leads with ignorance
Only Fools would rush in
thank you
[Music]
this is no victim
this is a lion killer
with gut piercing horns and a temper to
match
run and hide little boys
you're nobody on your own
celica's Army is coming of age
they thrive on chaos
[Music]
and finally have the numbers
foreign
power
on an assassin
they've been beaten to this feast
alone zalika is no match
but her new Shadow Army could devastate
this loner
[Music]
be afraid
they are fearless
and Rising fast
[Music]
timana leads her hungry family back to
the den
but something is wrong
there's a sweet smell of blood in the
air
in the trees
the trophy of an assassin
a dog killer
there's no choice now
just
Milan knows they must leave
The Hideout has been compromised
malau's injured brother must keep up
foreign
the pups have to adapt quickly to life
on the Run
scavenge whatever you can
you will need your strength
it is the worst of times
the once great Marsh
is dust and Bone
second Karma's sons have gone
but he still has mouths to feed
[Music]
his river is dry
foreign
[Music]
s have left
only hunger remains
[Music]
his Queens still have faith in their
King
but for how long
oh
they have company
the two younger princes are back
thank you
to beg forgiveness
said Ketty could not lead them after all
[Music]
in their wake tale between his legs
The Prodigal Son returns
humiliated
now has a choice
forgive his son
or punish him as a traitor
and exile circade for good
his majesty chooses Mercy
second Karma Knows the risk
foreign
[Music]
but is willing to gamble for the reward
he needs the unified strength
they don't know it yet
but second karma is on the brink of an
audacious decision
there is not enough food here
he has no choice but to abandon his
beloved Marsh
his loyal Pride follows
into the unknown
ruling only where they stand
they leave their home behind
finally the tyrants have gone
salik has been waiting for this moment
the new era can begin
she moves unchallenged into a once
forbidden bird
even the precious water hole is now hers
[Music]
fresh with a new fallen Giant
foreign
this windfall is her Shadow Army's
gruesome reward
[Music]
salika's reward
is the kingdom
she has finally done it
she is absolute ruler of the marsh
foreign
[Music]